few things are more satisfying than
seeing a character get destroyed in one
hit especially if said character has
been made to look strong and unstoppable
however even when the victim isn't a top
tier fighter seeing unadulterated
destruction like this makes me so happy
after all the victor does get his
oftentimes defining moment in the show
something which fans will talk about for
years to come so in this video i'll be
sharing some of my favorite one-hit
knockdowns in anime let's not waste any
more time and jump into the list no
rankings this time and i hope you enjoy
it
we start off with what i'd call a
defining moment for hunter hunter
[Applause]
a cool thing about storytelling whether
it's anime or otherwise is that the
entire tempo the entire feel of a show
can change in just a single moment one
swift event is all it takes for people
to realize that hey this might not be
your typical anime after all hunter
hunter has got a lot of these moments
and by the time kilowatt versus jonas
happened people already knew they're
staring at a gem of an anime that still
doesn't diminish the impact of this
fight especially given what happened how
often do you see someone one shot anyone
by literally ripping his heart out
this moment probably solidified the fact
that hunter hunter isn't your typical
shonen if it hadn't been already it's
not afraid to put his punches and it's
not every day you see these kinds of
anime go past the bounds of stand and
shone and violence and give us such a
graphic display of destruction or while
one of the good guys looks unfazed doing
it this moment caught some people off
guard and i sure think that statement
still holds true to this day what a way
to assassinate someone
a fight in bleach often lost in the
footnotes is the next moment on our list
do you still remember who ken bach's
last opponent in the anime was i won't
blame you if you don't since reception
for the full bringer arc has been
middling your best i also won't blame
you because the fight was over faster
than you could make a coffee heck
kempachi and giriko spent more time
talking than actually fighting you
expected a big throw down that would
push kenpochi to his limits or well at
least something that lasts long despite
the majority of it happening off screen
like yummy nope kenpachi just finishes
the fight the kenpachi way a clean
bisection ending the fight in one hit
looks like our bloodthirsty friend just
got even stronger after the time skip so
much for giriko putting on all those
theatrics and blabbering about his
powers ken butchie don't give a damn is
this the shortest fight in all of bleach
or what i mean i don't have a way to
fully confirm that off the top of my
head but it's got to be somewhere there
right
fairy tale has a lot of these one-shot
fights that has become a meme but i
think that natsu vs blue note is one of
the instances where the one-hit ko feels
very satisfying
[Music]
fairy tales post timeskip avatar arc
kicks off in a big way setting the gears
off with an invasion of margaret town
courtesy of the guild orochis finn
leading the charge is an old familiar
face blue note stinger from the 10 row
island arc yes that guy who gave gildan
to run for his money is back and now our
heroes have to take care of him without
their most powerful member wendy and
sharia find themselves struggling
against his gravity magic then natsu
just comes in and we all know what
happens next he knows sales gravity
magic and absolutely dumpster's blue
note with fire dragon king's raw and
just like that invasion over and the
heroes have won i wouldn't put it any
other way post time skip blue note has
become a joke i know the fight was
written this way to make natsu look
strong but this is really pathetic for
someone who pushed gildans to the limit
back in tenro island he had all those
years to train too not good for blue
note but hilariously entertaining for
fairy tale fans
one shot fights are commonplace if
you're god suya so mahoka gave us one as
early as the first time
with all the memes floating around it
doesn't take a lot to know that mahogany
has a lot of these one-shot moments you
know scenes that just showcase how
almighty our protagonist that zuya is
compared to all the puny ants in the
mahogany universe mahuka's pretty much a
series of tatsuya flexes one after
another my favorite has got to be the
finger snap of doom versus masaki but
that battle is more of an evenly matched
and drawn out battle believe it or not
and even had dasuya suffering lethal
injuries that he didn't have the ability
to just resurrect himself so we move on
to victim number one arrogant schoolmate
hanzo taking tatsuya's weed
categorization to heart if you're so
confident in being able to win a duel
should be an easy battle against one of
those weak underdogs then right all he
has to do is to aim his cat out skill
him in magic casting and oh no that
ought to show the guy hanzo better stop
looking down on weeds because just like
any schools grading and categorizing
systems student evaluations may be the
most accurate thing in the world
demon slayer makes an appearance with
zenitsu shining moment
tinitsu is known for many things mainly
unflattering things like the noise and
the crying and the huge crush on nezuko
however while he may seem to be the most
timid and bumbling within tanjiro's
group of true companions don't let the
reputation fool you most remember the
natagumo mountain arc for the legendary
hinokami kagura and the first direct
involvement of the pillars however i'm
sure that most people would agree that
zenitsu also stole the show with his
battle against the spider demon heck if
it weren't for tanjiro's moment i think
that this would be the moment of the arc
where an unassuming zenitsu finally
unloads the power he's been hiding
inside with a one-shot victory granted
it's not against a super significant
enemy but you gotta admire zenitsu's
spirit to unleash this while suffering
from all the injuries he already had i
dare say that in this arc he's actually
the most badass of the group and that's
including the carmando siblings in the
equation there i said it
aston versus seki's up next and is this
one pretty stomp
ever noticed that a lot of these moments
so far involved one arrogant jerk
getting put in their place yeah here's
more of that this time coming from black
clover magic jewels form one of the most
fundamental trials for aspiring magic
knights so you'd expect a couple of
rotten eggs and [ __ ] somewhere in
the tournament
astar faces one such jerk in sekke who's
so confident that he can easily defeat
asta it's not hard to see why
objectively speaking zeke feels that he
has fully prepared for whatever arsenal
can throw his way with his impenetrable
shield too bad for him though his
pitiful shield is no match for arsenal
and he gets one shotted in a shocking
turn of events in hindsight the moment
feels like it can be diminished due to
sekki holding back but i don't think
that matters when we all saw this moment
it sold us on black clover and it's an
awesome one-shot knock down whichever
way you put it
next up in line is mikey's one shot on
hanma
tokyo revenges has hit the ground
running and has quickly become this
season's phenomenon blending together
the fun aspects of the time travel story
and japanese delinquents is quite the
novel premise and it does open up to a
lot of fights where both combatants dare
to go down and dirty with each other of
course fights of that nature also opened
the doors for some of the most
satisfying knockdowns and in this series
one of the more notable ones is when
mikey just flat out one shots hanma with
a kick i just love the way the moment
gets built up with all the trash talking
mikey receives then without another word
he just finishes it and follows up with
his own chilling one-liner all that
after mikey just got beaten to hell and
back it's so satisfying to see an
arrogant slob get what's coming and
hanmar gloating before getting destroyed
also doubles as one of the most
gratifying moments in the show i could
just feel the emotion in that kick talk
about making an impact am i right as we
continue with the list let's feature
everyone's favorite one-hit wonder
saitama
saitama has made a career out of
one-shotting enemies that we all know
among all of them which one is his best
though it varies from person to person
but personally i think that the second
args climax against kabuto is the best
one what i love about this scene is that
it already established what a threat
kabuto was he already beat jenos
beforehand and he still had a lot of
tricks up his sleeve then we see him
suddenly retreat from saint arma out of
instinct is that danger sense that works
so effectively when presented in visual
media intuitions are often correct and
all the more so for garbuto nope that
new form isn't going to save you and
neither is that head start you got in
roughing side armor up not when you're
up against the strongest hero of them
all one punch is all it takes your time
is up kabuto at least gobbled up an
impressive spectacle of an offensive
that would put jojo to shame no matter
how futile it ultimately ended up being
lastly we wrap this up with a one-piece
moment
knowing how big a fan i am of the series
of course we'll have a one piece moment
in here my one hit knockdown of choice
for the series is luffy versus bellamy
now let's start with a question what
kind of one shots do you like the one
where the hero just tanks or avoids all
attacks before responding with a
stomping or the one where the victim
never even gets a chance to gloat if
you're in the camp which prefers the
former then
this one's for you to be fair to bellamy
he got to show off his arsenal with
luffy not wanting to fight him he gets
free reign and the green light to start
firing himself into a supposed enemy
then he just had to make the mistake of
insulting luffy just before going for
his final attack
big mistake luffy just destroys him in
one punch just like a good hero should
do considering what happened earlier on
in the arc this is easily one of the
most satisfying moments in one piece
now that i'm done i'd like to know what
your favorite one-hit knockdowns in
anime are it could be serious or the
comedic ones just take your time to
share your thoughts in the comments
section below you could surely come up
with something that i may have
overlooked and i'd love to learn about
more moments like these if you enjoyed
this video don't forget to like the
video and share it with your friends you
can check out both memberships and my
patreon all which are linked below for
more ways to support the channel your
help would be very much appreciated i'll
be looking forward to seeing you for the
next video videotube signing off for now
and i'll see you next time
[Music]